when it's chapter 2 hits theatres there
will be blood lots and lots of blood
director and EMU sketti and star Jessica
Chastain revealed to the crowd at San
Diego comic-con that one set piece
features more fake blood than you've
ever seen in a single scene we're
talking 4,500 gallons in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly Chastain
opened up about filming the gory moment
what was it like shooting them led scene
it was gross
and but it was fine
was it though you may recall that in its
chapter one young Beverly has a messy
encounter with the evil shape-shifting
entity which usually appears as penny
wise a dancing clown while inside the
bathroom of a father's house she
investigates the source of mysterious
children's voices coming from the drain
in the sink
[Music]
as soon as she gets close enough the
plumbing backs up a little bear as
Plumbing tends to do but then the sink
unleashes an unearthly geyser of blood
as plumbing generally tends not to do
the supernatural skirmish leaves the
screaming girls soaked in gore and she's
beyond confused when a father can't see
the mess at all but plug in a brief
moment from the final trailer of its
chapter to adult Beverly appears in a
bathroom covered in blood and we
strongly suspect there's a glimpse of
the scene everyone's talking about while
speaking of San Diego comic-con Chastain
revealed that she told me sketchy to go
buckwild with buckets of blood according
to he got discovered she said I was like
no if we're going to do it let's do it
I love horror films I love Carrie and
they said let's make Kerry on steroids
and that's what we did and it literally
tortured me because I didn't realize
that it would be that way the whole
movie we're not sure exactly what
Chastain means by the whole movie
judging by the trailers she does not in
fact spend the entire film bathing in
blood we think she means the film
effectively doubles down on the gore in
it chapter 1 if so we're totally here
for it new Scottie provided the 4,500
gallon figure which may or may not be a
record it was widely reported that
director fede alvarez used no less than
50,000 gallons of fake blood for the
final climatic scene of 2013's Evil Dead
climb will tell which scene as the
bloodiest of the two in any event new
sketchy statements lines up with remarks
Chastain made during an appearance on
The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
there's a scene that someone said on set
that it's the most blood that's ever
been in a horror film see in am innocent
it also squares with something it's
chapter 2 screenwriter Gary Doberman
told The Hollywood Reporter I know the
particular scene you're talking about
and there's no way to do it without a
ton of blood
knowing Andy he always takes things and
multiplies them which is what you want
out of your director it's pretty
incredible
the screenwriter also revealed that he's
seen the finished film and he loved the
end results I'm very very happy and I'm
very very proud I don't know you can
hear the joy my voice as I try not to
answer this question but I'm very
excited for everyone to see it as a very
very anxious person
I have no anxiety about that movie
whatsoever
he's not the only one who's excited both
em films are based on a 1986 novel
written by Stephen King who recently
took to Twitter to share his own opinion
of the movie looking forward to it
chapter 2 you should be I've seen it and
it's terrific if that's not enough to
pump you up we don't know what is be
sure to mark your calendars in Chapter
two flows into theatres on September 6th
2019 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]